okay so let's talk about the third and
last presidential debate tonight we know
what the numbers look like going and
they're not good for Donald Trump that
they're they're just not good there
there's no way around it you hear every
once in a while Drudge Report posts that
if you look at the Rasmussen poll
between 50 5 and 5 10 p.m. eastern time
it looked like maybe Trump was within
the margin of error right I mean you
have to have these incredible of silver
lining sort of optimistic ways of
reading polls to think Trump is doing
anything anywhere but we have a debate
tonight and Donald Trump could
conceivably do something now there's
sort of a few major media issues going
in and Hillary Clinton needs to
strategize around how to address these
there are but it's now an endless list
effectively of Donald Trump sexual
assault accusers top trumps excuses have
been laughable right there was one
accuser touch even keep track of it one
accuser Trump said I have no idea who
that is I've never met that person well
turns out five months ago he remembered
in vivid detail not only the
conversation he had with her but meeting
her parents etc for the guy who doesn't
really forget very strange defense with
the UH journalist Natasha stone off
Trump initially said look at her if you
need to think about or figure out why it
is it's unlikely that I would sexually
assault her now most people who don't
sexually assault women that I know if
you say did you sexually assault that
woman they don't say no I didn't and her
unattractiveness is proof of that they
would say no I don't sexually assault
women so sort of weird path to go down
with drunk Donald Trump we have this
long list right 17 of these women at
this point this will likely come up in
the debate tonight so the question for
Hillary Clinton is how to handle that
how to address that I believe that
Hillary Clinton should not address it in
any way she should we see these sort of
non questions in the debates where Trump
is asked to comment on the accusers and
then Hillary Clinton is asked to comment
about people accusing Donald Trump of
sexual assaults not really a question to
Hillary Clinton right it's just sort of
comment about allegations against your
opponent tonight people have heard about
the allegations I don't know that
there's anything to gain for Hillary
Clinton in
uh continuing to talk about it if she is
given the opportunity to comment about
the sexual assault accusers she should
say I'm here to talk about important
political issues facing Americans the
allegations against my opponent should
be evaluated by voters as I'm sure they
already have the voters will determine
whether these allegations are something
that impact who they want to vote for as
far as I'm concerned I'm here to talk
about issues facing the American people
now that might strike you as a
completely disingenuous response we we
all know Hillary Clinton no doubt has
many thoughts about these accusers but
from a strategic point of view I think
that that would be a much better
approach especially under three weeks
out from this election now there's this
other angle which is the rigged election
stuff that Donald Trump has been talking
about and he's been going at this pretty
hard saying if I lose on november eighth
uh we'll be able to attribute it to a
rigged election and he he sort of throws
anything he can think of into this
rigged election story he'll talk about
the emails which no doubt showed that
the Democratic National Committee did
have its hand or finger or entire body
on the scale in favor of Hillary Clinton
against Bernie Sanders but that doesn't
mean that the 50 individually regulated
50 plus one individually regulated state
elections on november eighth are rigged
and in fact that this is an area that I
think Hillary Clinton could really go
after Trump on because she can say even
your own Republican cohorts Republican
governors are saying wait a second I
don't support Hillary Clinton as a
Republican governor but if Hillary
Clinton wins in this state it is not
going to be because the election was
rigged we are carrying out a fair
election here uh and then the other
question I'll have watching tonight's
debate is will there be a discussion
about poverty which has been essentially
missing from the first two debates and
the vice presidential debate are we
going to hear about climate change later
on in the show I'll tell you sounds like
the movie groundhog day yet again last
month the hottest month on record for as
long as we've been up at tracking that
data
and we've seen two minutes in these
first two debates about climate change
Hillary Clinton and Donald Trump they're
in a race to be effectively leader of
the free world and they've spent under
two minutes on the topic of climate
change into 90 plus minute debates it's
absolutely embarrassing the debate
organizers should be embarrassed the
candidates should certainly be
embarrassed milania's hugely embarrassed
but not about this right she's
embarrassed but about other things it'd
be great if she paid attention to what
was going on quite with climate change
so the topics that come up tonight will
be interesting and lastly Chris Wallace
from Fox News is moderating tonight and
this is the first time a fox news host
has moderated one of the major
presidential debates they've done the
Republican debates they've even done
Democratic debates those are organized
between the parties and the network's
this is actually organized by by the
Commission on presidential debates so
it'll be interesting to see what dynamic
he brings I know that there are people
already saying and I'm getting emails
hey fox news host running a debate
obviously it's going to be super
friendly to Donald Trump I actually
don't think so I think that Chris
Wallace is I would expect Chris Wallace
to press Hillary Clinton but I am
convinced that he is absolutely going to
press Donald Trump and Chris Wallace has
never struck me as the type of guy that
would be titillated by the prospect of a
Donald Trump presidency so that's what
I'll be watching for tonight and
tomorrow we are going to have analysis
we will have clips and highlights and uh
so much more send me your thoughts what
are you watching for in tonight's debate
I've talked about how people of all ages
but particularly Millennials are owning
cars less and participating more in the
sharing economy and one of the more
popular options is zip car which gets
you a car when you want it when you need
it they offer all sorts of cars SUVs
hybrids whatever you need it includes
insurance and it includes gas you just
pay for the time that you actually use
the car and you can reserve the car
online from your smartphone over the
phone then you unlock it with your
zipcard each car share member reduces
their personal co2 emissions by between
1100
1600 pounds per year for our audience
zipcar is offering $25 a free driving
credit if you sign up at joined zipcar
dot-com / David support our show reduce
your carbon emissions and you're
spending on cars sign up at join zipcar
dot-com / David